let me ask the craziest question
indulge me for a second oh uh
this is a joke look at what we've been
talking about like okay no all the
seatbelt on
all of this is assigned all of that
despite the
the caveats about armchair i think is
within the reach of science
uh let me let me ask one that's kind of
um also with the nursing science but
as joe likes to say uh it's entirely
possible right
uh is it possible
that uh with these dmt trips when you
meet entities
is it possible that these entities are
extraterrestrial life forms
like our understanding of little green
men with aliens that show up
is totally off i often think about this
like
what would actual extraterrestrial
intelligence
look like and my sense is it would look
like very different
from anything we can even begin to
comprehend
and how would it communicate and how
would it communicate would it be
necessarily spaceships
right travel or could it be
communicating through
chemicals through if there's the pan
psychism situation
if there's something not if i almost
for sure no we don't understand you know
a lot about the function of our mind in
connection to the
fabric of uh the physics of the universe
a lot of people seem to think we have
theoretical physics pretty figured out
i have my doubts because i'm pretty sure
it always feels like we have everything
figured out until we don't
right but i mean there's no grand
unifying theory yet right but
even widely recognized we could be
missing out
like the concept of the universe just
can be completely off
like how many other universes are there
all those
all those kinds of things i mean just
the the basic nature of information the
uh time time all those things yeah
well yeah what yeah whether that's just
like a thing we assign value to or that
whether it's fundamental or not that's
whole sean
i could talk to sean carroll forever
about whether time is emergent or
fundamental to the reality
but is it possible that the entities we
meet are actual alien life forms
do you ever think about that yeah yeah
yeah yeah i do
and and i've to somebody relayed my
cards out with
by identifying as a radical empiricist
you know it's like
so the answer is it possible and i think
you know ultimately if
you're a good scientist you got to say
now that's at the extremes it's a
like yes yes you know and it might get
more interesting when you had to
you you're asked to guess about the
probability of that is that a one in a
one in a million one in a trillion one
in a one in
uh more than the number of atoms in the
universe
uh probability and is like what
what is a good testable like how would
you know the answer to that question
well how would you be able to validate
it i mean well can you get some
information that's verifiable like like
um
information that about some other planet
that that or some aspect some
and gosh it would be an interesting
range but what range of discovery that
we can anticipate we're
gonna know within um you know
whatever a few years next 5 10 20 years
and seeing if you can get that predict
that information now and then
over time it might be verified you know
the type of thing like
you know part of einstein's work was
ultimately verified not until decades
and decades later at least certain
aspects through the
um through empirical observations um but
but it's also possible that the
the alien beings have a very different
value system and perception of the world
where all of this
little capitalistic improvements that
we're all after like
predicting the concept of predicting the
future too
is like totally useless to
to other life forms uh that have
that perhaps think in a much
different way maybe a more transcendent
way i don't know but
so they wouldn't even sign the consent
form to be a participant in our
they would not yeah that would not uh
and they wouldn't understand the nature
of these experiments i mean that
um maybe it's purely in the realm of uh
the the consciousness the thing that we
uh talked about so
communicating in in a way that is
totally different than the kinds of
communication that we think of
as on earth like what's the purpose of
communication for us
for us humans the purpose of
communication is sharing ideas
it feels like like converging
like it's the dawkins like memes it's
like
we're sharing ideas in order to figure
out how to
uh collaborate together to get food into
our systems and
procreate and then like murder everybody
in the neighboring tribe
because they they'll steal our food like
we are all about sharing ideas
maybe uh it's possible to to have
another
alien life form that's more about
sharing experiences
you know like it's less about ideas i
don't know
and maybe that'll be us in a few years
yeah how could it not like instead of
explaining something laboriously to you
like having people describe the
ineffable psychedelic experience like if
we could
record that and then get the nearer link
of
50 years from now like i'll just plug
this into your just transferring these
yeah it's like oh now you feel what it's
what it's like and like in one sense
like how could we not go there
and then you get into the realm of
especially when you throw time into it
are the aliens us
yeah in the future or even like a
transcendental temporal
like the us beyond time like i don't
know like you get into this role
there's a lot of possibilities yeah
but i think you know there's one
psychedelic researcher that's who did
high-dose dmt
um research in the 90s who speculated
that
um that and there were a lot of alien
encounter experiences like maybe these
are
like entities from some other dimension
or
he labeled it as speculation but you
know do you remember the name
oh rick straussman over here who did
yeah yeah the dmt work
he labeled it as speculation but you
know i think that
yeah i think we'd be wise to kind of you
know find it's always that balance
between
being empirically grounded and skeptical
but also not being and i think in
science well often we are
too closed yeah which relates to like
you're talking about elon like
in academia it's like often like i think
you're punished for thinking or even
talking about 20 years from now because
it's just so
far removed from your next grant or for
your next paper
that you're it's easy pickings yeah and
you know that you're not allowed to
speculate so i i think though
i'm a huge fan of i think the work the
best way
to me at least to practice like science
or to practice good engineering is to
like
do two things and just bounce off like
spend most of the time doing the rigor
of the day-to-day of what can be
accomplished now in the engineering
space or in the science like what can
actually what can you construct an
experiment around
do like that the usual rigor of the
scientific process
but then every once in a while on a
regular basis to step
outside and talk about aliens in
consciousness
and uh we just walk along the line of
things that are outside the reach of
science currently
uh free will the
the illusion the illusion or the
perception or the experience of free
will
of anything just just the the entirety
of it
being able to travel in time through
warm holes it's like it's really useful
to do that
especially as a scientist like if that's
all you do
you go into a land where you're not
actually able to think rigorously
there's something
at least to me that if you just hop back
and forth
you're able to i think do exactly the
kind of
injection of out of the box thinking
to your regular day-to-day science that
will ultimately lead to breakthroughs
but you have to be the good scientist
most of the time
and that's consistent with what i think
the great scientists of history
like like in most of the
the history you know the greats you know
the newtons and
uh you know einsteins i mean they were
there was less of an in this change i
think as time
marched on but less of a separation
between those realms it's like
there's the inclination alpha it's like
as a scientist
and this is like this is science this is
my work
and then this like my inclination to say
oh lex don't take me too seriously
because this is my armchair i'm not
speaking as a scientist
i'm bending over backwards you say you
know
to divide that self and maybe there's
been less of there's been that
evolution and and that's and like the
greats like didn't
see that i mean newton and you go back
in time and it's like that obviously
like connects to than religion
especially that is the predominant world
where
newton like how much you know like how
much time did he spend trying
to like decode the bible and whatnot you
know maybe that was a dead end
but it's like if if you really believe
in that in that particular religion
and you're this mastermind and you're
trying to figure things out it's not
like oh this is what my job description
is and this is what the grant wants it's
like
no i've got this limited time on the
planet i'm going to figure out as much
stuff as possible
nothing is off the table and you're just
putting it all
together so this is kind of these
trajectories related to this
the siloing in science like again
related to my like oh i'm not a
philosopher
you know going whether you consider
science or not not empirical science but
like
going to these different disciplines
like you know the greats you know didn't
you observe the balance the boundaries
didn't exist
you